Hey, David, both Biden and Trump are older
and have political problems that might prevent
them from making it to November.
Who are the likely Biden and Trump replacements
if they don't make it to Election Day?
So we'll deal with Biden first and then talk
about Donald Trump.
It's a little bit of a weird question, but
I I'll I'll answer it.
If you don't believe Joe Biden is going to
make it to November.
I presume you mean because of his age?
Because I don't really know of what else is
going to knock Joe Biden out.
I know that there are people saying he should
resign because he's been accused of sexual
assault.
That's not really the way things work in the
United States.
Right?
Republican, Democrat, for better or for worse,
in particular, Joe Biden's winning every national
poll and even competitive in a bunch of red
states that Trump won easily.
You don't usually bow out when you're winning
every poll.
So people who are, you know, using hashtags
about drop out Biden and this sort of stuff
for me.
Biden is on the ballot in November unless
he's dead or in a coma by that point in time.
Now, maybe there are people, again, who are
thinking that the terror Reid thing is going
to make Joe Biden step back.
I just think it's it's unrealistic.
So if Joe Biden doesn't make it to November
because he dies again, I think that's really
the only way that it happens.
It would seem natural that it would be Bernie
Sanders who would replace Joe Biden in the
sense that Bernie Sanders had the second most
delegates during the primary before dropping
out.
I think what would complicate it is if Biden
chooses a running mate soon, you would have
a debate.
If Biden chooses a running mate and then for
whatever reason, cannot continue the campaign.
I think he would have a fight between whether
the running mate replaces Biden or whether
Bernie Sanders replaces Biden.
I think it would be horribly toxic and divisive
and could probably end up hurt helping Donald
Trump.
I hope it doesn't happen.
All right.
That's on the Joe Biden's out side on the
Trump side again.
I assume people are talking mostly because
of age.
Trump's not going to be removed by impeachment.
He's not going to be removed by the 25th Amendment.
He's not going to be arrested or anything
like that.
So.
Maybe, maybe people think Trump is in his
70s and in poor health.
So maybe that's what they're looking at.
I think Republicans go right to Mike Pence.
I don't think there's any question whatsoever.
I don't think there's even much to debate.
I know that the idea has been floated of maybe
Trump would replace Pence for his 2020 run.
Obviously, that ship has sailed.
The Trump Pence 2020 signs are everywhere.
Mike Pence has been made sort of a figure,
a prominent figure in the Corona virus task
force, despite despite being a complete clown.
Trump has made him a prominent figure in the
briefings, et cetera.
So I think it obviously goes right to Pence.
Don't see it going any other way.
If you disagree on either, if you disagree
on what happens if Biden doesn't make it to
November or if Trump doesn't make it to November,
let me know.